auf geht es gleich mit dem messer los
aber ich muss nur mit ins programm
posting machen heute kommt die frucht
tat online
ich weiß nicht ob ich das bild nehmen
soll
jetzt habe ich post ein beamter oder auf
dem video keine ahnung
jetzt gibt's gleich los gewinnt gerade
auf der messe in dortmund
heute ist sonntag der zweite tag es geht
gleich los
und jetzt nicht nur unsere musik laufen
lassen letmeentertainyou und dann geht
es um mein gott es zwischen 253 und dann
warten zwei in zwei minuten gehen die
tore auf also muss man einfach hinten
nach vorne
ich muss mein posting später
betrifft unser lied und alle stehen da
vorne
jetzt ist aufgegangen
so aufgeregt
heute kündigen 58 dann waffen das ist so
cool
ok
für uns einfach alles
ist der wahnsinn
mein schiff
heute gibt es ein kleines the scenes
video es wird kein rezept führungen
sondern ihr werdet jetzt einfach mal so
ein bisschen mein messer alltag
mitbekommen gegen dortmund gestern war
die hölle los ist kommt gestern nicht
irgendwer muss um punkt zwölf gedreht
und heute möchte ich euch mitnehmen ein
bisschen was zeigen diese täler gestellt
es gab eigentlich schlafen meine cousine
hat einen kinderwagen gefahr
findet ihr alles gerichtet für uns
nichts vor gefragt
gibt es
ganz viel wasser
am kuchen alles mögliche und jetzt gehts
gleich mit dem rad geht dann raus und
dann komme ich raus
dass ich meine zehen zu mister glauben
immer noch aufgeregt
kurz vorher
dienstag im rathaus
uns ausgehen
dadurch aufgeregt jahre alt
hey
heute ganz schön wenig
teure silikon
roma
vor
straßen
obwohl
eine sprühflasche
inzell
unterricht draußen
was eigentlich immer nicht aufgedeckt
die ganze zeit kurz vor
erreichen
und der moment
schön
ab
ausgenommen
dass ein zuschauer ansprechen
münster
gefährlich
da
labels
wahrscheinlich nicht ganz voll aber
jetzt schon jetzt haben
mal
welche marken zugesehen
am sonntag
den dank
da
wasser gebracht
vielen dank
menschen videos anschauen so viele da
stehen mir die videos anschauen wenn
menschen sie dann
das einfach nicht bewusst später wenn
natürlich auch zusammen
unterstützer
ich versuche mir immer so viel zeit
den einzelnen
am liebsten würde ich mit jedem einzeln
vortreten gehen aber das geht leider
weise die nächsten fünf jahre
beschäftigt jeden fall
sie gleich starten
81 erledigt braucht
juli
an
leichter
guck mal ganz gut
da hab ich jetzt gestoppt
freude
aber alle die da gewandt haben
buchen
die weiterspielen kommt zu dir über
einen drehstuhl
bis gleich
die uhr habe ich glaube
euro
dior gestellt aber es kommt keiner
lingen
christian
es war ja noch ein rockkonzert
die kommen
damit die anderen gewannen
je
und ganz liebe grüße
die maya unterliegt
die betreffen
meine fans
ein dritter gelangt
karte und
in ihren spielen
andere
freundinnen
und jetzt
im ganzen land
mehr
danke
allein
für den ersten block geschafft
eine pause so kassen stehen so wieder so
viele andere wohl abgesperrt haben und
jetzt warten die da
ganz vorn damit ist erlaubt
wieder raus die küche ganz gut
ausgestattet
damit mag sich später wieder in die
autogramme
man schläft
mit schreien erlebt
silly
ich hab mich voll erwischt da hingegen
über den verkauf gemacht und dann haben
wir wirklich sind gegessen habe
bremen
aus
händewaschen geschrieben wie sylvester
in die hände
unternehmen rausgeschnitten aber jeder
weiß schon mal wichtig
immer regelmäßig die runde
ein baby update hat würde ich gern
demnächst wieder machen weil seit dem
letzten baby ab seit dem 11
sechs monate hat es sieben monate alte
katze mittlerweile schon wieder ganz
viel dazugelernt sie kann sich nämlich
komplett drehen und wenn man sich hier
hinlegt dann ist es zwei minuten später
da drüben weil sie sich einfach hin mehr
wollt und das ist schon ganz viel also
die lernt wirklich jeden tag soviel dazu
ich möchte auf jeden fall wieder ein
baby ab machen aber da mache ich dann
immer so dass man sie gar nicht sieht
und ja sie trotzdem investieren aber
immer von hinten oder so und ich glaube
es reicht dann auch
am liebsten bücher kochen und backen
aber wenn dir zum autogramm haben würde
mich gern in der küche aber für ein
recht machen
er zählt zu den arzt oder
autogrammstunde am hof dass ich jetzt
irgendwie alle noch dran war auch wenn
ich möchte das thema so weit her
gefahren
geht deswegen bin ich jetzt ganz schnell
ihr dürft gerne mit dem rad
mit einer von kabels ist denkbar
jährlich
richtig viel länger in der küche mit
euch zusammen aber irgendwie ich mich
auf die aufgabe ich helfe über eine
autogrammkarte schreiben sie den schwung
bis hin
welche unter dem vorjahr und er ist aber
immer schön
liebe leute sind nur spielerfrau
ich bin auf sie zu
und nochmals erlebt wir müssen gleich
gehen
übernehmen
keine autogramme
auch genau und damit die letzte
autogrammstunde
aber geschafft für dieser messe damit
abgebaut indem ich euch
jetzt gehts denn die letzte
autogrammstunde für heute die zwei tage
waren echt super anstrengend
jetzt gebe ich nochmal alles und ich
glaube es stehen doch wieder eine gar
nicht hab gedacht ich hab eigentlich
schon geschafft aus weil er mit dem klub
so viele leute da zusammen gucken
beschreibt die letzten autogramme und es
war echt schöne messe aber es war auch
sehr anstrengend und vor allem das
stehen macht mir darüber zu schaffen
aber es ist wirklich sehr schön
ich muss jetzt doch was süßes glaube ich
besorgen und sie ist also noch mal in
die letzte runde
also auf der messe in dortmund waren
wirklich ziemlich viele besucher da und
hab ich was sage ich habe glaube ich
mehr autogramme gegeben alles gekocht
und gebacken
sogar der morath autogramme gegeben
das einfach keine eigenen
autogrammkarten ja ich war wirklich sehr
schön und es hat mich wirklich super
gefreut und ja es waren sehr aufregende
tage und hat dem nächsten jahr wieder
auf messe und sind wieder unterwegs also
die letzte messe dortmund ist natürlich
jetzt echt schon eine weile her das war
ja im mai genau und die nächste messe
wird die ifa presse in berlin sein und
zwar bin ich da am 4
auf dem stand von de'longhi und den
ganzen tag also wir sind wirklich von
morgens bis abends da uns wird mehrere
koch shows geben natürlich gehe ich dann
auch autogramme und ja da wird viel
gekocht gebacken
diesen trend also den ganzen tag weil es
einfach sehr sehr viel zu sehen
genau das ist auf jeden fall die nächste
messe dann bin ich als er für die iv
müsse haben wir 50 grad gott ganz
vergessen wären 50 karten zu verlosen
das heißt wenn ihr auf die ifa messe
kommen wollt und gerne eine dieser
karten gewinnen wollt dann schreibt
einen kommentar unten in die kommentare
und wer verloren sie genau 225 km 25 x 2
karten oder 25 20 für eine große tür und
20 x 2 karten 13 ethik gewinnen wollt
schreibt sie in die kommentare
und wir werden euch dann schriftlich
benachrichtigen übrigens du auch
die meisten zuschauer du hast berlin
zuschauer also jedenfalls freue ich mich
das sehr drauf auf die messe in berlin
berlin eine super tolle stadt
und da dürfte mich gerne besuchen kommen
es gibt noch ein paar events die ich
jetzt auch gleich ankündigen werde und
zwar bin ich arm nach der berlin messe
am 4.9 bin ich am 17
offenbach offenbach es bei sinsheim und
zwar hat da meine freundin jasmin die
hat da an beauty lounge und macht da ein
ganz großes event und das ist am 17
da werde ich auch mit dabei sein und ja
da freue ich mich wirklich schon sehr
traurig familie genau im gegensatz zu
berlin berlin sind liegen zwar nirgendwo
zuschauer
der zuschauer soll ein einwohner aus
welt wirklich super schön und da gibt's
auch essen und trinken und es wird
wirklich super schön nicht können okay
da freue ich mich drauf dann bin ich am
24.09 im september also auch noch in
sankt wendel und zwar beim globus markt
und werde dort auch eine autogrammstunde
geben da freue ich mich auch schon sehr
darauf denn es hat mir wirklich schon
einige aufwendige schrieben und am 8
oktober bin ich in rüsselsheim weiter
neueröffnung von globus markt mit dabei
und am 15 bis 17 oktober das geht dann
wieder drei tage ist die cache world
messe in hannover
und zwar mit auf der infa messe in
hannover und die kate geht dieses mal
von samstag bis montag also 15 bis 17
oktober und da gibt es unser ganz
normales programm da sind wir mit meinem
messestand kompletten team
genau letzte mal für dieses jahr ja dass
die letzte eigene messe sagen ich wie
gesagt auch also die wird auch sobald
und dann bin ich noch am 29
in bayern da fange ich auch immer ganz
viele wann ich denn mal nach bayern
kommen also 29 10 in plattling
das ist auch im globus-markt und da wird
es dann auch eine autogrammstunde geben
und da könnt ihr mich dann eben auch
kennenlernen
also das sind sechs termine und alle
irgendwie ganz woanders aber ich freue
mich natürlich auch auf alle meine
zuschauer die kommen werden
und ja die nächste ifa messe die kommt
jetzt und wie gesagt eigentlich fast
überall zu essen und zu trinken von uns
nur eben nicht bei den autogrammstunden
ja also ich freue mich auf euch und alle
weiteren infos gibt's auch sally shop.de
da unterkategorien messer stehen noch
mal alle adressen alle daten und alles
was sie wissen einfach kommentieren
25 5 und zwei karten
und wir freuen uns auf euch